Maybe like 100 questions, you
get panicked and so on.
So it's better to directly go
take the quiz than knowing all
these, you know, meta data about
exams.
Let me just quickly share my
screen.
So the morning session you had
ideas class today, right?
There's no confusions on that.
OK, OK.
Yeah.
Is it now clear the audio and so
there was, you know, Charan had
told this that in a lot of noise
and so on?
OK. OK.
Yeah.
So this teams upgrade has, you
know, changed all settings to
default.
Yeah.
So I had to just go and check,
you know.
Do we get an answer for this?
Yeah.
I just answered it right, Kumar.
Yeah, it is in abstract.
I know when Italy as well.
So actually we are on
assignment.
We got to use that binary tree
editing, so we were just
thinking that it will be more if
we use BST it will be more
efficient.
That's why we are asking.
Yeah, this question, huh?
OK, OK, now I get the point.
But but I would suggest if it is
given in the question just to
use binary tree then go ahead
with binary tree.
But mention in the document.
Yeah.
You'll be preparing a document
where you can mention that you
And said that, you know,
obviously would be more
know a BST would be more
efficient.
efficient and so on.
And so on.
Yeah, that would be better.
Someone is not muted.
OK.
Someone is not muted.
No, Sir.
Since morning, we were facing
such kind of issue that echoing
Since morning, we are facing
such kind of issue that he going
in all the classes.
Most of the classes.
Most of the classes OK and for
all of you.
OK.
And for all of you, when did
this get upgraded MS Teams?
When did this get upgraded MS
Teams?
Showed.
Yeah, I think I mean that's the
problem.
Uh.
Yeah, I think I mean that's the
problem.
The upgrade is the problem.
So last class we didn't have
this right.
For last class we didn't have
this right.
Uh PARTHASARATHY, it has been
upgraded yesterday, so last
class there was no problem.
Correct.
OK, fine.
I mean, let's see you know how
this goes.
But yeah, these have to be
planned and done.
There are like 20,000 people,
you know, in bits will be itself
using this.
I'm not sure how this sudden
upgrades are happening without
you know.
Anyway, I will have a, you know,
talk to the team when in need,
but yeah, only when in need.
You can just unmute yourself.
Otherwise it should be fine, but
for now it's fine, right?
You are able to hear me because
that's the first thing.
Yes, yes.
Sure.
Cool.
Yeah, cool.
Yes. Yep.
I think then let's get started.
And of course, sorry for the you
know, uh, swapping.
So I had to travel for some, you
know, events.
And I was just back and.
Cool.
So let's get started.
So welcome to the 8th contact
session for data structures and
algorithm design and what we'll
be doing is we will complete BST
deletion.
Yeah, we have not looked at
that.
We'll complete that and then we
will start a new topic called
hashing.
And, you know, collisions and so
on.
So what we will do is we'll have
a recap, but today's recap,
we'll do it differently because
today's the last class before
exams, right.
So firstly, we will go ahead and
cover the topics and before the
last more thing, we will take a
recap of the whole course.
Yeah.
Not just, uh, the last class.
So we'll complete BST deletion.
We will have a look at what is
hashing.
How do you resolve it?
What is, you know, collision and
all those.
So over here, we will take a
complete journey so far, like a
revision of what we have done so
far and we will also have a
discussion about our mid some
exam right.
And there are a couple of
techniques which are a part of
this module, but only few would
be covered today and only those
will be for your exams.
Yeah.
So these things we will not have
it covered today, we'll do it
after mid SIM and for exam as
well.
These would not be there, yeah.
So there's a question, Sir, one
out regarding as invent design
document and technical report
are the same way to do.
Yeah, there's just one report.
They'll have that you have to
submit and that should have
everything.
Yeah.
So there are also details on
what all can go in in your
report, right?
You'll put pseudo codes, the
analysis of it, the complexity,
alternate techniques,
everything, but just one
document.
It could be both design
technical you know details and
you know algorithm analysis.
Everything can go into that one
single report.
Yeah, PDF report and then a
contribution excel sheet and
your actual Python program.
Yeah, no need of, you know,
separate, separate, different
different things.
So you can follow that cool.
So let's get started.
So what did we do?
Last class I remember most of
you were attending so.
BST was not the concept that we
started.
We were doing something else.
So what really was that?
So what was that?
It was BV FSN DFS.
Then we started with PST.
OK, perfect.
So what we actually did was we
completed our whole graph
concept of you know traversals
and you know how do you do and
DFS was very you know aggressive
in nature it used you know stack
whereas BFS was you know more
cautious it used a queue and all
those.
So after completing all those
aspects, we then went ahead with
another data structure which was
BFS, BFS or I mean breath BST
and BHAT was nothing but your
breath.
You know search tree, binary
search tree and it was a very
promising data structure which
was promising login complexity,
but finally there was some case
which betrayed us.
Yeah, you also remember that
case.
Anything which is less than the,
you know, no data that will go
to the left greater than will go
to the right.
Greater.
Yeah, but there was a case
because of which, uh.
Yeah, it wasn't.
It was cute.
Cute data.
Your data.
Yeah.
Scared.
Yeah. Perfect.
Yeah.
So for small replays you can
actually, you know, post in the
chat.
So I love to see the chat for
you know these.
You know, when I ask, you know,
small questions like this, but
when you have a doubt, if you
are not able to, you know,
convey that better in the chat
at that time, of course you can
unmute and, you know, explain me
the question, yeah, that would
be great.
So yeah, stupidness.
Yeah.
So skew nudeness causes a lot of
problems in computing, right?
So that brings the complexity
back to.
You know, we go off N so that
was a problem that it suffered.
So we will also have a look at,
you know in the later part of
your semester, how do we resolve
that and you know, things like
that.
But in particular, in BST we
learned about what is it and how
to, you know, create one like
the installation part of it.
We also learned how to find
something in a BST.
So what type of technique we
use?
If it is not skewed, if it is a
normal BST, then there was a
concept of computer science that
we used there, right?
We remember that term.
Yeah.
So you start from the root.
If the number that you are, you
know trying to find is less than
that, you go to the left side
and then if it is greater, you
go to the right side and so on.
By doing that process, what are
we actually doing?
Yeah, I had mentioned that.
Anyone.
So when you're performing some
operations. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, very good.
It's pruning right.
You are trying to somehow, you
know, prune one part of the tree
and you are ignoring it because
you are very well sure that if a
number is less it should be on
the left side.
It cannot be in the right side,
right?
So we did pruning of some
branches and that in turn
promised a good complexity,
right?
But in general BST was still big
O of N because of that skewed.
You know use case and where was
the minimum in a BST, the
minimum in a whole BST.
Where would that be?
So it will be a node on the left
side which doesn't have a left
child.
Correct.
The left most one in the tree
would be the one which will have
the minimum value and who will
have the maximum.
He'll be the right most one
without a right child.
Yeah.
Perfect.
So these all things we learned,
we learned about insertions and
for deletions.
I had told that there are three
different cases and that is what
we are going to look at today.
So firstly in a delete when we
want to delete something in a
BST, there is this first aspect
of firstly it should be there in
the tree, right?
There could also be a key that I
gave that is not even there, so
I'll have to search for it.
I'll do the normal way of, you
know, searching where I go.
Left or right based on the node
value.
If that key is present, I'll
perform the deletion, otherwise
I would just return a message
that it is not possible.
If it is present and if I want
to delete them, there are three
cases.
Yes, the note that I want to
delete maybe a leaf node or it
could have one child or it could
have two children.
Yeah, this one child could be in
either left side or right side
no problem.
And these two children anyway,
it will be in both the sides.
So we'll look at each of these
cases.
Yeah, case one is the node that
we want to delete.
So we usually call it a zit.
Yeah.
Zed is the you know, the notion
of that node that we want to
delete node Z to be deleted has
no children, meaning it is a
leaf.
Then what is the procedure?
Just remove the node, modify Z
parent to replace the node with
null right?
So for example, is this a BST?
Firstly, it is a binary tree.
Very good.
And then 529710, all of them are
smaller than 1215201713 or
greater than 12, and for every
you know node two is smaller
than five.
These are greater than five and
so on.
So there's a BST, yes.
So now the number that I want to
delete or the element that I
want to delete is 17.
So firstly, I'll do a search
right 17 is greater than 12 so I
go to the right side, 17 is
greater than 15.
I go to the right 17 is less
than 20, so I come to the left
and 17 is found here.
So since 17 is found, we will be
able to delete it, right?
We want to delete it and we see
that this is in case one because
this is a leaf node.
So all that I have to do is just
knock him off, right?
I can just knock him and here
the left of 20 will become null.
Firstly, I have another
important question for you.
What representation would you
use to represent this BST?
Yeah.
Think about it.
They've spoken about all this.
Yeah, summer.
Is it right we will use linked
list and not an array?
Yeah, this is not a complete
binary tree.
If you use an array, you will
waste a lot of space here
because left and right side of
two are null.
You'll have a lot of nulls.
So 15 doesn't have the whole
left subtree at all.
So array is not a good way.
You will be using linked list.
Yeah.
So in the linked list, the left
side of 20 initially it was
pointing to 17, but now it will
become null.
So case one is very simple.
Just knock that leaf.
That's it.
So seven, we want to delete
seven from this BST.
Seven is smaller than 20, so you
go to left.
Seven is smaller than this 10,
so you go to left.
Seven is greater than six, so
you go to right.
Seven is smaller than eight, so
you go to left and you found an
element which is exactly equal
to the node that you want to
delete.
So what you will plan to do is
you'll just knock this off and
the resultant will be something
like this.
Yeah, his deletion clear for all
of you.
Case one, if the node that you
are planning to delete, if that
is a leaf node.
Yeah, just delete that node.
There is no other problem at
all.
Yeah, try to also delete 35 from
the above 3.
That's also leaf.
You will go ahead and find it.
You will delete it.
Now let's go to case 2.
Case two is all about the node Z
to be deleted has one child, so
remove the child so meaning that
zed whatever is there deleted
but modify Z parent to .2 Z's
child.
Yeah.
So I prefer to call this as
short circuiting.
Yeah, there, there is also some
literature that talks about this
word.
So for example, let's delete 40.
So firstly I want to find if
what is there or not.
So 40 is greater than 20, so I
go to the right side and 40s
found there's 40 have children.
Yes, it is not a leaf node, so
I'm not in case one, I'm in case
2 because it has only one child,
right?
So these are not it's direct
children.
These are grandchildren.
Yeah, we should only be
concerned about the immediate
child, so it doesn't have a
right child, but it has a left
child, so only one child it has.
So we are in case two.
So this case 2 deletion is all
about deleting these two entries
and making 20 as the parent of
30.
Yeah.
What does this line telling
modify Z parent?
So in our case Z IS40Z parent is
20, modify him to .2 Z child
which is 30, right?
Yeah.
We will go there.
Yeah, that is the third case.
Yeah.
So in this case I'm going to
delete both of these.
I'm going to directly draw an
edge from 20 to 30.
Yeah, is the case too clear for
all of you?
For example, I want to delete 15
here 15 is less than 20, I go to
left 15 is greater than 10.
I come here.
I got 15 here.
It has one child, so all that
I'll have to do is I'll have to
delete these two.
And who will become the right
child of 10?
Yeah, the right child of 10.
Yeah, that's right.
18 will become the right child
of 10.
Perfect.
So case 2, all of you are clear.
It is called as short circuiting
because we are just delete these
and connect Z parent 2Z child
simple and deletion of two
children.
Yeah, someone had asked in
between also.
So that's a very interesting one
and is also a tricky one.
Do you guys remember we learned
2 terminologies called successor
and predecessor.
Yeah.
Do you remember?
Who was the successor and
predecessor?
Yeah.
So in this case I have BST.
What is the successor of the
node 20 so 20s here, right.
Right.
I mean the root.
So who is this successor?
Yeah, 25.
And what about for a 10?
That's right.
Yeah.
So very good.
Yeah, I think you are revising
things, maybe, I don't know,
because of assignments or for
exams, but successor is
basically in the right side.
Who's the smallest right for
this whole right side of 20?
There is 40302535.
All of them are greater than 20.
We know it, but in that, who's
the smallest 25?
So 25 is the successor of 20.
Similarly for this ten.
Yeah.
The only one that is in the
right side is 18, so he becomes
the successor of time.
Yeah.
So this concept we have already
learned in the last class, right
and predecessor is something
different.
Yeah, predecessor should be in
the left side in the left side.
If you take the largest right,
yes, no.
Should we take the largest or
minimum?
Yes, no.
Meaning.
So in this case, what did we do
in the right side?
We took the minimum right in the
left subtree.
If you take the maximum then
that would be the predecessor.
Cool.
So this is the point why we
learned it.
Now we will see why that is very
important.
So when we do deletion in BST
and when we are in case 3,
meaning you find the node that
has to be deleted and it has two
children.
So if it has two children, then
for that node which you are
planning to delete, you have to
find the successor.
Or you can also do the
predecessor, but we will not
cover that, but it's exactly the
same.
Yeah, you can either replace
that with a predecessor or a
successor, but I would prefer to
go this way.
Always find the successor and
replace them right?
I mean in general terminology
also right?
I mean, who is going to take
care of your legacy?
Is it your successor or or is it
your predecessor?
I mean, technically speaking,
you can always, you know, do it
with the predecessor also.
But yeah, so always you can go
with the successor approach.
Predecessor will also work.
That is not wrong.
Yeah, you can, you know, find
the predecessor and replace him.
But I will always use the
successor technique, so you will
find the successor of that node
which you are planning to delete
which has two children and then
replace the element at that node
to be deleted with the element
of the successor node.
The moment you do this, what
would happen?
There will be a duplicate right
so that duplicate has to be
removed.
Apply removed to the right
subtree to remove the duplicate.
So this duplicate again can
either fall into case 3, case
two or case one.
You get it right?
So let's take an example.
It'll be one more clear, so here
is a BST for us and I want to
delete the Note 9.
So nine is here and it has two
children.
So since it has two children,
I'm in case 3.
So who's the successor of nine?
Yeah, this node is the one that
I want to delete.
So I validated in a different
color and it's successor is 11.
11.
So I found out right in the
right subtree of nine, the
smallest is 11, so he's the
successor for now.
What I should do is I have found
it out already in the right
subtree.
I found out the mean value which
is successor.
I'll copy this value into the
node that I plan to delete, so 9
is what I wanted to delete, so I
copy this 11 there the moment I
do that my deletion is over
correct because my 9 is already
gone out of this tree.
So but I have a duplicate 11 so
this duplicate level which I
have at the bottom.
This is what I want to delete
and this 11 deletion which case
is that?
Yeah.
So does it have zero children?
One children, two children.
So this this is having no
children so it is case one.
Because it's you kiss one.
Yeah.
So I'll just delete him.
Kiss me.
Yeah, the whole 11 I deleted and
what remains is my output.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
But let's take another example.
Yeah, but the concept is clear,
right?
Whenever we are in case 3 for
the node that you want to
delete, find the successor.
Copy The same successor value in
that node the moment you do
that, you're deletion is over,
but by doing so you have
introduced a duplicate and that
duplicate one.
You have to delete, which can
either be one of the other
cases.
So let's take this example.
I want to delete six itself.
What did it mean duplicate Sir
duplicate here.
But the successor value?
Ohh.
Yeah, this one that we had, you
know, this is what we got
OK, OK.
copied, right?
So in this three there is 2
lemons, so you should not end up
deleting this level.
Yeah, because that was a
position where your nine was
there.
So by duplicate I mean the
original successor.
This is.
That is what you have to delete.
Yeah.
Is it clear?
Coolest has a question.
Yes.
Uh.
Can it be said that we are
swapping zed node with its
successor and then perform
deletion?
Perfect.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
You are.
You you're not actually
swapping, but you're copying.
But that's also right.
You could also swap.
The nine would come here and
that nine can be deleted.
Good.
In this case I want to delete
six and at which case I mean.
Six has left.
Also, six has right also, so I'm
in case 3 right?
At this.
It has both the children, so in
the right side I want to find
out the minimum right the six I
want to delete in the whole
right subtree.
I see who's the smallest.
It is 8, so this eight is the
successor of 6.
So I copy this 8/2 that node, so
I'm going to copy this eight
here.
The moment I've copied it, my
six got deleted, but now there
are two eights here, right?
There are two eights here and
this 8.
The successor node is what I
want to delete and now this is
which case because this eight
also has children.
So is it case one case 2, case
3, just case 2 because it has
It's too.
one child, so if it is that,
what should I be doing?
I should do short circuiting,
meaning I should cut this tie
between 11:00 and 8:00 and I
should join it like this.
Right.
So then 11 will point, it's left
will have only nine and 10,
right?
I I've deleted this one, this
one I've joined 11 and 9.
Cool.
And what is the time complexity
of deletion?
Big of yen because of what?
Stupidness great, I have a
complete skewed tree.
If I want to delete the last
leaf if I'm in case one, I'll
have to traverse all the way
till that and that is big of end
correct cool is BST deletion
clear for all of you?
Promising guy, we learned a lot
about BST, right?
Simple stuff.
If it is the node value smaller
it goes to left side.
If it is greater, goes to the
right side.
That helps us in, you know,
pruning and insertion Max, min,
deletion, all of it we learned.
But finally there was that small
case of cuteness.
Because of this, this whole data
structure is again back to big
of young.
Yeah.
Can we have example of case 3
resulting in a case 3 Sir.
Yeah, you could also have
something like those also right.
For example, in this example, if
this eight also had left
children right then that can
also be there.
No.
Why it can't happen?
So this eight was our, you know.
It will be the smallest.
It will not have any left child
after that.
It would be the smallest.
Uh-huh.
When we are finding a successor,
there'll be no left child of it,
because then that left child
will be the successor, not 8.
That's perfect.
Yeah, in BST it will not happen,
but in AVL it will happen.
So I just, you know, got
confused with it.
But you're right, in BST this
case 3 will only result again in
case one or case two.
Yeah, but there is another tree
that we will learn which is on
top of this BST.
Yeah.
So that is the very next tree
that we will learn.
And they're also you have
deletion and there that will
result in a lot more cases.
Yeah, email deletion itself has
three, and this also has another
three and all that.
Yeah.
Cool, but you're right.
Yeah.
Thank you for that.
So in this case in, when you are
in case 3 after it's deletion,
you will end up because I see
rightly pointed.
So if you are trying to create
or find out the successor, so
that will not have another left,
right.
So in this whole right subtree
that will be the minimum, which
means it doesn't have a left
side. Right?
Cool.
So if this operation happens in
left subtree, then we need to
replace.
No, no, no, not at all for the
whole tree BST deletion means
either you can go for successor
approach if it is in the left
side.
Also you can find out that
successor and do it.
Yeah, no problem with that.
All good with your BST.
Yes, no, maybe.
Cool.
Then let's get started with the
next one, which is hashing
right.
So you might have learned a lot
of these applications even in
our Python course we learned
about, you know, this.
So a hash table or you know this
is one of the presentations of a
dictionary, right?
So where you associate certain
keys with certain elements, that
is what is a hash table.
So hash table is a data
structure used to store key
element pairs.
Yeah, the key and element
together is called as an item,
right?
So for example, if there are a
lot of, you know students, so I
can consider all of those as
elements.
So for all of them, I give a
roll number that becomes the
Right.
key.
So if I use this key and element
put together that is an item
right?
So keys are then used to insert,
search or remove.
So if I want to delete a student
entry, I will just use their
role number for searching for
removing, for inserting or
anything.
So many applications are there,
for example address books host,
you know, name mappings and so
on.
So this hash table actually
consists of two major
components.
It is made up of two things,
which is your hash function and
a bucket array, or it can also
be called as a the table itself.
Yeah, this is exactly like
Python dictionary, correct?
Yeah.
So this is the actual concept
and in Python And other
languages it has been
implemented right?
This is an abstract data type
and in most programming
languages you have one or the
other forms of hash table you
have hash table, hash map or
dictionary, right.
Several implementations of the
same concept.
So what are these?
Right.
What is a hash function?
What is a bucket array?
So a bucket array.
First, we will see what it is.
A bucket array of size N,
meaning it's a simple array.
Each cell is thought of as a
bucket, right?
For example, if this is an
array, so how many elements do
we have?
We have 11 right zero to 10, so
each one of them you can assume
it to be like a bucket and yen
defines the capacity of the
array.
If the keys are integers well
distributed in the range 0 to
north minus one right, we will
also look more into this.
It will be clear an element E
with key K is inserted into the
bucket of K great meaning there
is an element who has a key SK
to you will go to that K
position and you will put this
element.
For example, the bucket for
items with key as six will go
into this bucket, right?
For example, someone with six
chocolates, right?
All of them will go into this
bucket.
Someone with two will go to this
bucket.
So is the bucket array part
clear?
It is just a simple array and it
is going to have a maximum
capacity of north.
This is 1 portion of the hash
table.
The important portion comes
next, which is your hash
function.
But before that you might have a
question.
If it's just a ARAY then what is
the difference between a normal
array and a hash table right?
Something like this?
So what is the difference
between them?
Yeah, there is an array here.
So insertion time is lesser and
even searching time is lesser
There's an hash table.
because with key element we can
find the element and insert the
Uh-huh.
element.
Right.
But just by looking at these,
what is the other difference in
this array?
Is there some keys associated
with them?
Guess no.
No.
No, Sir.
I can always argue that there is
a indexes and that index can act
Basically, index becomes the
key, yeah.
as a key.
Yeah, index can become a key,
right?
Because that is still unique.
This will be 0.
This will be 1/2 and so one and
it I can still use that right
index can still act as a key.
Then is an array hash table.
OK, let's clarify that myth.
Yes.
So in an array, these indices
are automatically taken from
zero to n -, 1, and they do not
have a relation with this value,
correct?
So for example, 011 is Boston
and two is Mexico.
It's just a normal ordering that
2 doesn't have a relation to
Mexico.
Or maybe it is not derived out
of this.
Mexico beat us in a hash table.
These keys have a relation with
this value.
Yeah.
So maybe I can tell in this
string how many you know vowels
are there.
I will count that and then that
can become its key or, you know,
things like that.
So these have a relation and
these two put together form an
item right?
For example, in a student set
your name and your role number
together become your identity,
right, whereas in an array, if
you just store all your names,
you will get some normal numbers
as 01234.
That 1234 is not having any
significance, right?
That is the main difference.
So let's go about.
What is this hash function now?
Right.
So the keys are not always in
the range 0 to north minus one.
They agree to that.
I'm just using a normal array
and that array has a maximum
capacity yen.
So all that I can store is 0 to
north minus one, but I might
have a key which is beyond N
also right?
So I'll have to somehow map it
into this range again, right?
For example, if I have a table
of size 10, I'm getting a number
which is 50, but I still want to
somehow map it into this range
of zero to 10.
So which function will help us
there?
There's a mathematical operator
who's that?
Yeah, Mark, very good.
OK.
Yeah, hash function helps to map
each key K to an integer in the
range of 0 to north minus one.
Right mod function helps us.
For example, H of K is equal to
X mod N is a hash function and
the integer H of X is called the
hash value of key X.
They are very, very important
ways.
Don't get you know, just carried
away with these definitions.
Let's break it down.
Yeah.
First of all, this high of OK it
is a function correct HO FKH of
X is equal to X mod N so this is
a function.
This X is some integer.
Yeah, you are going to, you
know, this is your some value
and then is also the capacity of
your array.
You put these values after you
put these.
You are going to get an answer
right this H of X answer you
will get and that answer is
called as the hash value or hash
value of this X.
Is this clear for all of you?
So you are given a hash
function.
You pass your key to it and what
you get is called as the hash
value of that key.
Yes.
No, all of you simple
definitions.
Hash function is given.
You pass your key to it.
What you get out of it is the
hash value and that hash value
will now be used to store this
key, right?
I'll go to that location and
I'll put this number there.
Let's go further.
Hash function maps each key K in
our dictionary to an integer in
the range 0 to north minus one.
So this very powerful line
simply says all the hash
functions are going to have in
some or the other form this mod
function, because if you don't
have the mod function then you
may exceed this range, right?
You you might not be able to
accommodate, so I need to have
that mod function where North is
also my capacity.
So use the hash function value H
of K as an index to the bucket
array, right instead of the key
key.
So let's you know, go further.
So we will come back to this.
There are some requirements of a
good hash function.
Which is it has two first
minimize collision.
It should be easy to compute and
so on, but firstly you'll
understand collisions and then
we'll come back.
So does an example of a hash
function H of K is equal to K
mod N right?
The absolute value we are
taking. Yeah.
So whatever is the key, I'm
going to give it to this
function.
I will get an answer and that
answer will be used in that
position.
I'll put this key K and the N is
the size of the hash table.
N is usually chosen to be a
prime number that helps to
spread out the hashed values.
Yeah, we will understand it's
importance in a minute, but this
diagram is a very good one.
There is a key. Yeah.
So this key itself is derived
from an item, correct?
So this diagram is not very
complete, so this is an item.
It has a key.
It has a, you know element.
It can have a lot of attributes,
right?
All of them put together is 1
item.
I take that key alone and I pass
it to my hash function and this
hash function.
One of the examples could be or
K mod N it could be anything.
Yeah, you calculate that, but
definitely it will result in a
value which which is in the
range of 02 and minus one right
in this range.
It should give me the answer, so
that value that I've got for
example, let's assume I got the
value as two that is called the
hash.
Do I leave off this key?
I will go to that second
position and I will put that
whole item here, not just the
key to the whole item.
You will put it there.
Great.
Is this clear for all of you,
the big picture of what hashing
is?
And then of course, if I want to
do search again, I will use the
same key.
I will come to the two and I
will see if it is there or not.
I'll go randomly, you know,
searching for all the, you know,
list.
I will not do that.
Yeah, but now there was this
line like, you know, this yen
should be chosen as a prime
number, right?
Why is that hash cannot have
null value?
Said no, it cannot, right?
So if the hash value if this is
a null, then where would you go
and store that particular item?
But it should definitely be in
one of these range 02 this n -,
1, so that you can go to that
location and put that particular
item there.
If this itself is null, then how
do you store that right?
Let's quickly do this.
Consider the following keys,
meaning again, a word of
caution.
In all my slides, I will only be
talking about the keys, but the
big picture is that each of
these keys also have a element
associated with it, right?
For example, this could be
someone's roll number.
Yeah, they have their names.
Marks address all of that
associated, but I will not be
depicting all that.
Typically in a Python that will
become an object and you can
store that object, but in my
examples I will just directly
put this key itself in that
location.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
All of you.
So for example, in this example
I told you right the right ways,
this whole item should go into
that cell, not just the key.
Yeah, but in these examples I
would just put the key and exams
and one also you will be only
given keys.
You'll not be given the whole
item and so on.
Right, Sir, can you give an
example? Brief?
Uh. Hash function?
Yeah, these are all examples.
Yeah, this is an example of a
hash function, right?
So let's go with this.
Yeah, we'll understand about
that more, Rajesh.
Yeah.
So we are we have given a lot of
keys 202 not 5 to 10.
All of these keys are given to
us.
Apply the hash function H of K
is equal to K mod 10 where K
IS202O5210 and SO1.
When you apply it, you will get
the H of K answers.
Similarly, we have also been
told when N is 101, then again
try to calculate the hashed
values.
So real quick do this and tell
me the answers for when N is
100.
Meaning, what is that you are
doing?
You are going to do 200 mod
hundred 205 mod 100, then 210
mod 100 and so on.
You will do it for the whole
list and give me one answer and
then you will do it for 200 mod
100 and one 205 mod 101 and so
on.
Yeah, they're already answers,
and I really love that real
quick.
Yeah, 051005100510.
Yeah, that's right, 051005100510
right.
Cool.
And what about the next one?
When you apply 101 right 200
modulus 101 is a 99, right?
Yes, no real quick who's doing
this calculation?
You have already calculators.
This would be a 99.
99389827 and so one, right?
That's right.
Cool.
So now if you just carefully
look at these hash values when N
was hundred, there are a lot of
repetitions right?
Meaning duplicates 0 itself is
coming several times 10 also is
coming several times five also.
But when it was one or one, you
did not have a lot of
duplicates.
Yeah, because I don't want his
prime.
And 100 is not a pro, but now if
you tell me just because I
choose a prime, can it guarantee
that there will be never a
duplicate?
No, it cannot guarantee.
Even if you choose a prime
number, there can still be cases
where there are duplicates,
yeah, but when you choose a
prime number with this example,
we are able to see that the keys
are the same.
All these keys are same for both
the example but when you took a
prime number the number of
duplicates have been reduced but
in a non prime number there were
a lot of duplicates so that is
why we had that line here.
Telling N is usually chosen to
be a prime number so that you
don't have duplicates.
What is this duplicate?
Yeah, if the zero if this zero.
If the zeros are the hashed
value so then this 200, then
this 300 and 400 are competing
for that same location which is
indexed by zero.
Is that correct and that is what
is called as collision.
A bucket can store only one
item.
Simple right?
So for example, in this case
everything is null.
And let's suppose I'm going to
count the number of.
Uh.
Say phones I have.
Yeah.
So John is having one phone
easier, right?
Mary has five phones, so she's
here.
But as Martha and Janet, both of
them have exactly 3 phones, so
they.
So that is the hashed value,
right?
The number of phones that they
have is the hash value, so here
it is 3, so both of them come
and collide here in this cell
which is collision.
This should not happen right
collision occurs when when can
it happen?
If two different elements have
the same keys, right?
If two different elements have
the same key then also this
condition can happen or when two
distinct keys K1 and K2 are
mapped to the same bucket in the
hash table such that H of K1 is
equal to H of K2.
In this example we saw it 203
hundred 400, all different keys.
But when you update your hash
function, your hash values were
all zeros for them.
Either this can happen or keep
themselves.
Could also be duplicates, right?
So in those cases, in both of
these cases, collision will
happen.
Yeah, that is where that
advantage came.
I should somehow choose the hash
function such that it can
minimize the collisions as much
as possible, right?
And what is one way to do that?
You already learned about it.
What is one way to minimize the
collision as much as possible?
Same number.
Uh prime number.
Yeah, exactly.
You will choose yen, your
capital yen.
That is the size of your hash
table to be a prime number.
But just because you choose
prime, it doesn't mean that it
will completely solve
collisions.
Collision will still happen, but
it'll minimize it and this hash
function should be fast and easy
to compute.
Yeah, you should have just
modulus function.
A couple of maybe
multiplication, minus,
subtraction, division.
All that this hash function
should not be a very complex
function involving, say you know
trigonometry, route and squares
and so on, because that will be
an overhead in computing just
the index.
Where is that item should go
right?
This collision has to now be
resolved.
We agreed.
What is a hashing?
We understood what it is.
We also saw what is collision,
but this should not happen.
Two people cannot come in,
collate to the same cell, so
I'll have to resolve this
somehow, and that is the next
one hour.
Yeah, collision handling or
collision resolution strategies.
There are several ways to deal
with this.
One is called separate chaining.
Yeah, another is called open
addressing.
Very important.
This separate chaining has
another name called open
hashing.
And this open addressing has
another name called as closed
hashing, right?
Can you give some examples of a
good hash function?
Yeah.
Anything that involves a prime
number is a good hash function,
right?
And which is also easy to
compute, for example the ones
that we were dealing here right?
Like K, modern is a decently
good I know hash function.
It's very quick to compute.
You know you can directly do it
in your, you know, just with the
register.
No need of anything.
And then it also has no value
which is A1, not one as a prime
number.
Whereas if you choose N as
hundred, that is bad because it
will result in a lot more
collisions.
Yeah.
So these names.
Be careful, guys.
Yeah, a lot of students confuse
open hashing with open
addressing.
No, just go with these names.
Yeah.
If you call separate chaining,
you'll have to call it open
addressing.
If you call these as open
hashing, this is closed hashing,
right?
So in separate training, you
don't have any sub cases.
It is only one technique,
whereas in open addressing or
closed hashing there are C3 sub
techniques.
You can either do linear probing
or you can do quadratic probing,
or you can do double hashing
right.
All the three is under open
addressing.
Yeah.
So Manish has a question, what
should be an optimal value for
the prime number to choose?
So that depends on the domain.
Yeah.
So how many keys you are
expecting and what type of
application you're using and
what is the suitable yen?
Yeah, it should not be very
small.
It should not be very large,
right?
And we will also have some
discussions later in the class
today like what happens when
that table is almost getting
filled, right?
What should we do?
Because if you have taken a
wrong choice, if you have taken
a small prime number right, then
what do we go about it later?
Yeah, we'll discuss about all
that.
Yeah.
Cool.
So now let's look at separate
chaining.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you.
Do you understand what we are
trying to do?
Hashing collisions and now how
do you resolve the collision?
Either you separate or go for
open and separate chaining is
what now we are going to look
at.
So what does this operate?
Chaining.
OK.
It's a very, very simple
technique.
Colliding item is placed in a
linked list right single line?
Same process.
You have a set of keys coming
in.
You pass each key to the hash
function.
What you get is called as the
hash value and go to that value
right if it is empty, go ahead
and create a linked list and put
that link list items address
there.
So technically in this separate
chaining mechanism, RMI actual
items there inside my bucket
array.
Yeah.
No.
Is it there?
No, not at all.
It's there outside, right?
Yeah.
So there was also another
question where do we use hash
table practically in most
applications, right?
You want a lot of quick
searches, then hash table is
your way right?
Because you are not going to
search the complete array.
Rather, you would quickly
calculate the hash value.
You will go to that cell and
only check there, right?
So it has a lot of advantages
and you know.
So yeah, so each cell in the
array stores a pointer that
points to a linked list of items
that are mapped to that cell.
Meaning, what can we tell so
about this three items, what can
we comment about these three
there is one commonality between
these three, what is that?
Yeah.
He.
Yeah.
What was that?
So we.
He.
Yeah.
The similar.
Come again?
Is it really a key or is it the
hashed value? Yeah.
Uh has value has finished?
Yeah.
So these but but you were on
another angle right there could
That's really.
But but but both both thing is
correct.
be all the three items same.
Yeah, both are correct.
Exactly right.
We saw about these line right
collision can happen when
multiple items have the same key
or their hash value are same
right?
Either there is a case where all
these items themselves are
exactly the same, meaning
duplicate data, or these items
could be different.
But after I applied the hash
function, the hashed value for
all of them has resulted in this
file, right?
That is what this means.
So let's go ahead and do some
other ways.
It is a null like all these
1011.
You know these places are all
null, so let's you know.
Of course, this requires
additional memory apart from the
table, right?
So in this case now I have this
bucket array.
I have the hash function.
I have this whole additional
space for linked list also.
There's a question no for you.
Separate chaining.
Insert the elements using
separate chaining in this order
into an initially empty hash
table using the hash function
hash of K is equal to K mod 13.
If I were you, the moment I read
till here, I will note down.
What is this 13?
What is this?
This conveys the yeah prime
number.
Prime number.
Trying to move.
Yeah, but what exactly is this
in our use case?
Yeah, it is exactly this.
Can minus one buckets, yeah.
And.
Then this is capital yen.
Yeah, very good.
SURENDRA was right.
This is capital N which denotes
the capacity of my bucket array.
So if this is 13, I'm going to
have my cells from zero to 12.
Show your work step by step and
we have been given some keys.
So the very first step is to
calculate the hash value, right?
Can you real quick do that?
Hash function is already given,
so this K is 90 then it is 41
So so.
then it is 36 and so on.
So 12.
Yeah.
What was twelve?
I didn't get that.
To 13 is your capital N yeah, 13
is your capital N meaning you
And then 12.
On.
have cells going from zero to
12, but 13 slots are available,
right?
So this this data structure is
created by US Pranav.
So this is a array data
structure.
This full is a linked list, so
we are only creating this using
two different data structures.
Yeah, it is not one out of the
box 1.
Please.
Have.
Can someone quickly tell me
these hashed values 90 mod 1341
mod 1336 mod 13?
Yeah, so 1212205.
No, switch to 10 by two, but.
Yeah, 12 to 10/5 to 12 to 10.
Umm.
Yeah, this is the hash value
right now.
We will be going ahead and, you
know, storing these using our
linked list and so on.
So Sriram had a question, is
there any order to be maintained
when we are storing the data in
language?
No, not at all.
Yeah, that that hardly matters.
Yeah, based on the way the keys
came in and based on the
insertion sequence, it is it.
So in between these two there is
no relation, right?
First one to you.
So this item is not related to
this or this item is not related
to this.
The only commonalities they all
ultimately pointed or collided
to this cell.
Yeah.
Yeah, someone has.
Uh, yeah, you can also mute.
I mean, if someone is uh, you
know, unmuted, you can just
maybe ping them or, you know,
try to mute them. No problem.
Yeah, I don't have a problem
with that.
Right.
Cool.
So the similar structure we have
seen somewhere and they're also
we had told there is no relation
between this item and this item
and so on.
What was that concept?
Exit adjacency list.
Yeah.
Perfect, very good.
Cool.
So then let's you know, go ahead
and insert these items.
Please were given hash function
is given you have already
calculated the hashed values.
So now we will have to insert
it.
So I've created a table with
size 13 going from zero to 12.
I'll have to store these keys in
this hashed value, so 90 goes to
12 right?
Should I directly put this 19
inside this?
No, I'll create a linked list
node and put 90 there and make
11.
this point to that node because
we are using separate chaining.
Next is 4141 should go to two,
so here I will create a node.
I'll put it there.
3636 should go to 10, right?
I came here.
It was null so I created this in
a.
Note I inserted it and now 1818
should go to five.
I come here 5 is null so I
create a node.
I make it to point to that 18.
Then you have 2828 is again
going to two.
So I came here.
I see it is non empty, meaning
there is already some element
who has its hash value as to and
now there is a new element which
is also two.
So what does that imply?
What has happened here?
What phenomenon has happened?
Collision.
Well, listen.
Great collision has happened, so
I will now create a new Note 28.
I will first traverse from 41.
I'll see.
Is it already connected with
something?
No, it was not.
This was empty, so I made this
point to 28.
That doesn't mean you know there
is a relation between this node,
and this is only the pointers
are connected.
Yeah.
And the next one was 1212, again
had a cash value of 12.
So I go to 12, it is non empty.
So I come here, I see 90s there.
It's next part is empty, so I
pointed to a new node which is
going to have this 54 again
points to two.
I come here collision.
I come here, 41 is already
there, 20 is already there.
Then this next part will point
to a new node which will have me
54.
Finally, 1010 goes to 10.
Then it's already having you
know, some values.
So go here, create a new node,
attach it.
So I'm done with the insertion
right?
So now I have a question for you
here.
What is the capital N in this
example?
13 umm.
Yeah, team correct.
Now I'm making a statement in
this separate chaining
mechanism, right?
I'm claiming that I will be able
to store 10,000 items.
Am I true or false here?
Yeah, in this exact same
example, I can tour 10,000.
Hopefully yes.
Yes.
This will get.
As a link list, yes.
Yes.
Yeah, that is true, because in
separate chaining you are not
storing in the table at all.
Anyway, these items are stored
outside, so let collisions keep
happening.
You will keep putting that in
the linked list nodes.
There is no problem, right?
So, Kapil says, uh, why to
always put that?
Uh.
End of list uh we can add just
as a first entry in the list.
Also, or would that be wrong?
It will not be wrong, but what
if I always already have a
duplicate?
For example, I wanted to insert
54 if I don't traverse this
list.
If I just keep on adding in the
beginning, what if there was
already a 54, right?
So by traversing this I want to
be sure that that item is not
there if that exact item right.
So two items colliding to the
same hash value is no problem,
but if two exact items are the
same then there could be a
problem, right?
Most hashing applications will
not allow two people to have
exactly same item or key.
Hash value is OK, but do we have
two other numbers as same?
No, right?
So in those cases I don't want
to allow duplicates, so I'll
traverse here and I'll also do a
check.
Or am I inserting a unique value
or is it already there?
But if you just insert it at the
beginning, then you might lose
out on such, you know small
checks someone was telling about
collisions or complexity, which
was correct.
Yeah.
It's big of north, right?
So far so good, all of you.
If exact item we have then what
we will not insert right?
Yeah, we will not.
We will just throw an error
telling that no, there is some
problem and we will not insert
it if exactly 2 items have a
same.
Yeah.
So this is the same thing.
Uh, I have just put the, you
know, actual diagram from here
this week created.
Yeah.
Understood. Kamal.
Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's how you have to try.
That's the right way of
thinking, but in this case, for
example, you want to allow
duplicates in your application,
you are not bothered and that's
the right way.
You can always, you know, add
something to the beginning of
it, but there is also another
doubt.
These are all singly linked
lists, right?
So how do you go about doing it?
So firstly you have to come to
two, then take this guy's
address and modify the new nodes
next part and then you'll have
to point this to the new node.
Is that correct?
All of you linklist concepts,
even if you want to add in the
beginning, you can't just
randomly add him here.
You'll have to first take this
40 ones address from here and
add them in our new nodes.
Next part.
Otherwise you'll lose this whole
link list, right?
If you just randomly, you know,
put the new nodes address here,
you'll lose this part, so it
should be really careful doing
that.
Cool, now we have understood
about insertion and there is no
limitation you can do any number
of insertion in separate
chaining because ultimately you
are not using this bucket, you
are putting it in linked lists.
Right, this is exactly the same,
uh.
Declare an array, initialize it
to null, find the hash key if
that you know key position is
null then make that point to the
node.
Otherwise, it means it is a
collision.
So insert the keynote at the end
of the chain.
Now we want to do some searches.
Yeah, my hash table is created.
I want to search for some keys
in that table.
What should they do exactly?
Same concept, right?
Compute I is equal to H of K,
right meaning whatever key Ki
want to search, give it again to
the same hash function.
Don't use other hash functions
right.
Whatever you used for insertion,
it is the same thing.
Pass it to the same hash
function.
You will get something called as
H of K which is the hash value,
or in other words the index.
Go to that particular cell.
If that particular cell is
empty, then what can I say if I
come here, I get someone's key
as seven.
I come here it is null.
It means definitely there is
nothing here right?
So I can tell that key is not
there no key, but if that key is
not null then if the key exists
return the index.
So basically we have to traverse
that list if it is there, so
we'll see some examples.
Now let's consider the same
example.
I want to search if 10 is there
or not.
So what should I be doing?
What is 10 mod 13?
Yeah, real quick 10 mod 1310
more 13 is 10 only.
And then anything.
Ohh.
Yeah.
How is equal to 10 more 13 which
is 10.
So you go to ARAY which is a of
10.
You see, this is not null, so
you have to traverse.
You first go to 3636 is not
equal to 10, so you then again
traverse 10 is equal to 10.
So search is successful.
Perfect.
What about 20?
What is 20 more 1320 more?
13 is 7, so you come to a of I,
which is a of seven.
7.
You go here, you see directly
here itself.
This is null.
There is no node or linked list
attached to this, so directly
you can confirm that 20 is not
there in my hash table.
But if it was an array, you
should have done a linear search
or a binary search.
But here what is the search
complexity?
It's constant here, right?
In this case, for 20 it is
constant.
You just come here.
You declare the 20 is not there.
What about 15?
What is 15 mod 13 Teen Mod 13 is
2.
You go to a of two.
You realize it is not null, so
you have to traverse.
You go to 4141 is not 1528, is
not 1554 is not 15.
So at this point is when you
declare that 15 is not there,
correct?
So what is the worst case here?
What is the worst case
complexity of search?
The one who answers gets a
goodie here.
Big open.
Yeah, because N again, correct,
people might go for.
Uh.
Or, uh, ego and so.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
Because if it is again skewed,
if all my N have colliding and
of all of them are like this,
then I'll have to end up
traversing this whole list.
So we go off North is my worst
case.
There's some small differences
for quiz and so on.
Right.
Is a difference between separate
chaining and open addressing.
So in separate chaining, the
keys are stored inside the hash
table as well as outside the
hash table.
It's a little misleading.
This inside is not the actual
value, it is just.
This addresses the address of
the first node, right?
Ultimately, this table still has
some data inside them which is
going to take you to the actual
data, right?
These addresses are metadata.
It is having something factual.
Keys are outside in the linked
list, but very important
difference in open addressing.
Open addressing has three
techniques, linear, probing,
quadratic probing, double
hashing.
In all of them, all the keys are
stored only inside the hash
table.
No keys present outside the hash
table, and you cannot use any
extra memory, anything.
The actual array itself will be
used only that should be used.
You have a deletion is easier.
How would you do delete again?
Same concept, right?
If you want to delete say 10, I
will first try to find him.
If I find him, I'll knock him
off and I'll make that next part
as null.
Yeah, deletion.
Is it clear for all of you
separate chaining?
Firstly, you will do a search if
you find it, you will go ahead
and delete it.
If I want to deal this 28, it's
a little tricky, right?
I love to join this 41 to 54 and
then only delete this 28
correct?
I cannot just randomly delete
this and keep quiet, so I'll
have to point the 28th next.
You know, this guy has to become
41 next.
Yeah.
Are you getting this?
Yes.
No, maybe.
Deletion right?
If it's only one like this
deleted if it's the last leaf,
just deleted.
If it's somewhere in the middle,
and so on, you'll have to.
The simple linked list deletion
concepts.
Yeah.
So there are a lot of other
differences like these, so you
can just, you know, go through
them.
And now we'll take a very quick
break.
We'll come back by, say, 5:00
o'clock and we will again resume
with this open addressing the
three schemes under it.
Yeah, we'll have a look at that.
Yeah, that I have a query
regarding the assignment which
you have given.
So so yeah, suppose like one of
our teammate, he has uploaded
Yeah, go ahead.
the assignment zip file from Mac
OS.
And what happened like while
uploading?
Uh-huh.
Like when I when I try to just
verify whether this like file
Uh-huh.
was uploaded properly or not.
So where we I downloaded it and
in my system I can see there is
an extra folder with name Mac
OS.
Yeah, that that's fine.
Mac OSX, right?
That's right, it's fine.
Yeah, that's fine.
No Sir.
That's fine.
That's all OK.
Then you should.
OK. OK.
Yeah, not a problem that.
Thank you. Yeah.
Then the file should be PDF or
DOC.
Uh doc filter because in the
assignment it is mentioned
docks, right?
Yeah, it was a little bit
confusing.
We we uploaded the docs file
only.
That's what.
That's also fine.
Yeah, as long as it is readable
document it is fine, but the
Umm.
whole thing should be a zip file
inside that zip file you should
have one contribution file Excel
file and then either a PDF or a
doc file and one actual Python
source program. Yep.
So then one more query, the
content like the design
document, we have 4 pages, OK
the first page and have some
Uh-huh.
team info and all.
So including that team info
page, it should be 4 page or
Uh-huh.
excluding that it.
No, no, all that is fine.
Yeah.
So as long as you know it's not
a very lengthy like 1020 page
document, we are OK with it like
a little bit here and there is
still fine like 5 pages, 6 pages
etcetera is OK because anyway
the first and last like you know
thank you or first page etcetera
doesn't matter.
So to the point of that is just
to convey that documentation has
to be precise but yet clear,
right?
Like you should not end up
writing, you know, like 50 pages
of documentation so.
So so today, today the
assignment will like the quiz
will be published, right?
Yes, from today 7:00 PM it will
be there till tomorrow.
Uh 11:55 PM I believe.
Let me just go back to that and
let me see, but I had posted as
announcement because it keeps
changing a lot with some
Yes.
batches, it still uh next day
night for some batches it is 7
to 7.
So let me just clarify.
DCD important.
For for all the like the
different subjects that we have
a a separate link like quiz.
So, but in DSD, we have a link
for assignment but quiz link is
not present in the left hand
side.
Yeah.
Yeah, it will become.
Yeah, I have not published it,
so it will be available from
Worked out OK, got it.
today 7:00 PM to tomorrow, 7:00
PM.
Yeah.
So it is 7:00 PM for your batch.
Yeah, that's good.
So the quiz will start today
7:00 PM.
OK.
It'll exactly end tomorrow, 7:00
PM, but in that 24 hour window,
once you start the quiz, it will
be for a smaller duration.
It could be for like 30 minutes.
It could be for 45 minutes.
It could be for one hour, not
more than one hour.
Yeah, it'll either be one hour
or it'll be 30 minutes, or it
will be 45 minutes.
Or it could be 15 minutes or
whatever, yeah.
And so that the assignment like
since it is a group assignment,
I can see only like if it is
submitted once, we cannot
resubmit it again.
Suppose if we want to do some
correction and resubmit that
Correct.
provision, is there? Yeah.
Yeah, there is only one
submission correct.
That's right.
So have you already submitted
and you want to do any
Uh set?
corrections now?
You mean the doc is fine, PDF is
not needed.
Yeah, he's suppose we want to do
anything.
Doc is fine, but are there other
changes that you want to make?
Not as of now.
Yeah.
Yeah, there is only one chance.
Yeah, I mean like that's the
right way.
OK.
I mean, otherwise you keep
revising and.
Actually, in course we got since
it was a group assignment, there
was some multiple like
submission.
It was there till the end of
permission date, so that's why I
OK, OK.
asked you the question.
No, no, they just one like keep
working on it.
Once you have the final one, you
could just upload that one,
yeah.
OK.
OK, fine, Sir.
Cool.
And suddenly in the document.
Yeah.
Sorry you had something? Uh-huh.
Uh.
Uh, like, do you do you like?
Is is it fine if we just have
the algorithm or do you want the
pseudo code and the code also in
the document?
No, not the code because code
anyway, you are submitting a
Python file which we will be
running.
Yeah, PY fine, yeah.
Yeah.
So you can just, you know, put
the algorithm and you know you
can analyze it, you can propose
some alternate techniques.
OK.
You can explain why you have,
you know written algorithm that
OK.
way.
Like what data structures you
used?
Of course, in some questions
already it was told what data
structure to use.
You can justify why that is the
right data structure to use, or
why that is not the right data
structure right?
OK.
All such you know, things you
can mention, yeah.
Yeah. Thanks.
And actually in in my team there
is one person whom we were not
able to get in touch with and
later on we found that he has a
dropped off from the course.
No, that's fine in the in the
contributions, she just put the
name and put 0% for that person.
Yeah, actually we have a screen
dump of the communication that
we had.
Can we attach it somewhere or as
a proof or?
You, you you can just copy paste
it inside the Excel sheet.
Excel itself.
OK, Sir.
Yeah, in the Excel itself, just
paste that you know
Yeah, thank.
communication and put 0% for
that person.
Yeah. Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
And so few people who don't even
reply.
OK.
I mean we have we are not sure
if they have there or not.
We don't have any communication.
Yeah, that's what like if you
have done the work, if someone
has not contributed, put 0% and
that proof of, you know whatever
you communicated but you didn't
get a response.
Don't worry about if they are
still in the program or if they
have left it and so on.
As long as you attach this then
we will take care of it, yeah.
And uh, Kapil has something can
discuss later to PS7.
I have some alternate approach
late point or you would first
want to check those invent.
Yeah.
Then only. Yeah.
Yeah.
Alternate you have to mention it
in the document itself now and
like you don't need to implement
the alternate version.
Yeah, you can just explain that
part, but may not, you know
upload two Python files and all
that, but that's pretty much
yeah.
And post evaluation and all that
you could, yeah.
Yeah.
Uh, I this is said, this is
Kapil.
But what if the alternate
approach sounds better than the
one mentioned in the assignment?
Ohh like has it already told
some data structure to use or
what do you mean?
Yeah.
So it was mentioned to use heap
OK.
Yeah.
Then you have to use heaps but
in alternate you can tell your
own approach, but if it has told
heap then adhere to only heap.
Although if it might not be the
best way do with heap in
OK.
alternate you can just counter
our view telling that yeah,
Yeah.
So that that is what I meant.
Actually, yes.
yeah, got it.
Yeah, so all the assignments
they have been told to user data
OK. Thanks.
structure to make sure you you
learn about the data structure
better.
Yeah, it may not be the best way
to do it.
Yeah.
So that is the purpose.
Yeah, in between someone had
something.
So Ruby, I think, and then, you
know, the ray came in and all
went in and chain.
So you still have something or
we go ahead, so Ruby.
No, Sir.
It's regarding only that tipping
quick quiz open till night Sir.
OK, that that I will see.
Because the other courses, if
it's still seven and only if I
No.
keep till 11, then there are,
you know like have had you know
like why only this course and so
on.
Got it, got it.
Got it, Sir.
So for all the other courses, it
is still 7:00 PM, right?
Or is it till 11:55?
And make for.
You said for some it was seven,
some 1159.
No phone calls.
It was still 12.
You forecast we have till night.
OK, OK, cool.
First, the US is it?
Let let me see that.
Yeah, I will check that, but it
will be it, it is not visible
for you now, but it will be
available at seven.
Yeah, so.
Uh, so for alternate approach,
can it be like into
probabilistic things?
Probabilistic thing.
Or for example, let's say uh,
there is more.
Meaning, what do you mean?
Uh.
Uh, there is a way to solve the
problem more efficiently.
If we apply probabilistic
algorithms.
No, no, no, it should be only.
From what we learned it it, it
should be some other data
structure or it should be some
other.
You know algorithmic technique,
not something like probabilistic
or using randomization or
genetic algorithms, or, you
know, such advanced things.
OK.
Yeah, it it has to be somewhere
around our own course.
Maybe I used a heap or you could
have used a graph or things like
that.
OK.
Yeah.
Cool.
Ah, but but doesn't
PARTHASARATHY today quiz will be
So we will take one more, yeah.
coming.
Just sorry, I missed the
communication.
Yeah.
Yeah, it will be.
It will be 7:00 PM today.
Oh, OK, OK.
Yeah.
So click syllabus for today
would be not till today's
lecture.
Yeah, it will cover something
till BSD.
Yeah, not hashing and so on
hashing we will have later,
yeah.
Cool.
I think then we will quickly get
started and.
Let's let me know if you are
still able to see.
OK, I just saw the reaction.
I was waiting for some reply.
Cool.
Yeah.
So let's go ahead.
So we'll listed about separate
chaining and open addressing and
now we will go deep into open
addressing, which are those 3
schemes.
So under open addressing, there
are three and what is the other
name of open addressing?
You guys remember that?
Closed hashing.
Yeah, close dashing.
The name is closed because the
bucket is closed.
You cannot go outside, right?
Whatever keys you get, you'll
have to manage it within the
hash table itself.
You cannot go beyond it.
Yeah, that's the logic for that
name.
So the first one is linear
probing.
So what is the normal word?
Probing.
Yeah, in the normal English
term, what really is probing?
Asking questions.
OK.
Sequential searching, sequential
searching.
Yeah, right.
Investigate.
No probing alone.
Yeah, probing means asking
question or investigating or you
know, things like that, right,
asking.
And if I do that linearly, that
is linear probing and that is
what we are going to do.
Linear probing handles
collisions by placing the
colliding item in the next
available table cell.
Next available meanings are
clearly meaning if the last one
is, you know, not available, you
will check the first one right.
You're going to check the next
available cell if it is free or
not.
Meaning we're going to probe it.
Each table cell inspected is
referred to as a probe in this
method, if we try to insert an
element K, comma B into a bucket
A of I that is already occupied,
what does it mean if it's
already occupied?
Right.
Yeah, if something is already
OK, it means collision has
happened.
Where is equal to each of K.
Then we try the next of I + 1
mod this mod N because we don't
want to stop at the last, we
want to also continue checking
in the beginning.
So this process will continue
until we find an empty bucket
that will accept this new entry.
So insert an item we have K
comma E where K is the key and
is the element.
This whole thing is that item as
usual.
Use the K and compute the hash
value or the index.
Once you compute that, go to
that AO fi and check if it is
occupied or not.
If alpha is not occupied then
place the element in a of.
I very good.
No collision, just put it there.
If the offer is already
occupied, if collision has
happened then try the buckets I
+ 1 model.
If this is also occupied then
try I + 2 mod N and so on until
we find an empty bucket in a
that can accept the new item or
we have inspected the entire
array.
It is I plus N minus one mod N
we have inspected, meaning you
have done a whole circle.
You are again back to that you
have not, you know, found an
empty place.
Then you cannot insert this item
right and like you are separate
chaining here, there is a limit.
That limit is nothing but your
capital.
If you have a array of size 10,
your bucket of size 10, you
cannot insert more than that.
Right, probe each table cell
inspector to place the item is
referred as the probe.
We already know that
disadvantage something is there,
we will come back after learning
what the disadvantage is right.
Firstly, what is this insert the
keys using linear probing in
this order into the hash table
using hash function H of K is
equal to K mode 13.
Show your work.
Step-by-step keys are given real
quick.
Let me know the hashed values.
529.
Yeah.
Flight 95 arrived, values itself
52957 then that it's the
Yeah.
contrary place in six and.
No, no, no.
That we will, that we will do.
Yeah.
So this is the hash values
right?
And now I have 13 which is our
capital N which is the capacity,
right?
So what we are planning to do is
we will first create a bucket
going from zero to 12 which is
this 13 done.
Now we plan to insert them 18.
Has this fires hashed value 41
has two, so all of you got the
hash concept right?
I mean Rajesh quickly, you know,
told the hash value.
I have also shown the answer
here, but all that you have done
is 18 more 1341 Mod 1322 Mod 13
and so on, right?
Simple stuff, no MFDS.
This is all basic.
You know modulus SO18 mod, you
know 18 mod 13 give you 5, so
we'll have to go to five.
I check if it is empty or not,
it is empty so I can just go
ahead and put this eight in
there.
So for that, there's no
collusion.
All happy case 41 is going to no
collusion.
21 should go to 9.
I go.
There it is.
Empty.
I go put it there, no problem.
44 should go to five and I come
here and check that is occupied.
So collision has happened and
this is where linear probing
came into action, where you went
to the next cell and you asked
or probed.
Is that empty?
And it was empty.
So you have actually put the 44
here.
5959 can go to 7.
It is already empty, so you'll
put that 59 there.
32 should go to six.
It comes to six what has
happened?
Collision.
So you probe the next cell that
is also having an item.
So again collision.
So you again probe the next
cell, it is empty.
So you put that item 32 here.
And then 31 is for five.
Again here collision linear
probe.
Check here collision check here
in seven collision check here in
eight collision check here in
nine collision 10 is it free you
will put that 31 here finally 73
again collision collision
collision.
Put it here.
Yeah, that's it.
In session is completed.
So now you how many more items
can be inserted in this
particular example.
Maximum how many more can insert
here?
Maximum typing 30.
By.
Are you?
Five.
Yeah, because only five more are
left.
Yeah.
Beyond that, I cannot.
It's like, you know, that is why
this is called as closed
hashing.
I cannot use any other linked
list or anything.
Yeah.
So what will happen if ARAY gets
filled?
Yeah.
Then you cannot insert.
You will throw an error that you
know you cannot insert, but that
is the you know, next concept we
will later look at.
Do you should never let the hash
table get full.
This is telling something like.
You know what is my hard disk?
Gets filled?
Yeah, if your hard disk is
getting filled, then you know
warning, right?
You know that, OK, 90% is filled
or so on.
So you will do something else.
Yeah, you will maybe take a
backup.
You'll make it free or you will
buy a bigger hard disk so that
we will do later if all cells
are occupied on the right side
That.
of five, will it occupy in left
side?
Yes, that is why we have this
answer.
Modeless right.
So if all of these are occupied,
then also what we will do is if
12, you know we will check 12 if
12 is also Cupid mean we will
again go back and check in zero
and one and so on.
Yeah.
Circular cool.
Yeah, someone had a question.
Yeah.
It only says Sir.
How is this different from
regular right?
So in regular array there is no
calculation of hashed value,
right?
If I want to now search for 18
in a normal array, I will go
search starting from zero.
I'll have to search where 18 is,
but here I'll put 18 to the hash
value.
I mean hash function, I'll get
fires answer.
I'll directly go there.
I'll get that answer.
If not, I will linearly probe
and check where it is, right?
So this is not a regular array,
correct?
So where a key is going is
determined by the hashed value.
But this way we can assign it to
the key, right?
What does it mean Shanshan
meaning to the right? Yeah.
So so if I if I, uh like we have
a three values or linked with
585 key for here.
Correct.
Uh-huh. Correct.
But if I if I see I if I see
this output, I cannot determine
which is actually linked with
file.
Correct.
Well, for me this is not.
I mean, I don't find it useful
because if I want to see what
exactly is linked with five
using only the below diagram, I
can.
I can see only 18.
I will not say the rest.
Yeah, that's correct.
Yeah.
So if you want to see or
visualize, then separate
chaining is the technique, but
separate chaining has a problem
of extra space, right?
If I don't want to use extra
space, I want to fit it in the
given bucket itself.
Then I have to somehow manage,
right?
So then this is 1 technique.
Yeah.
So in all the other two also you
will not.
And even for even for searching,
Sir, we have to search that
complete if the any element is
not found, we have to search
that complete list because we
don't know that which element is
Uh-huh.
related with any other key or it
is all of the same key.
No, no, no, no.
We we will go there.
We will go there.
No, no.
This is a very beautiful
concept.
Uh yeah.
We will learn that we need not
search the whole array.
That is the point.
If we search the whole array
then it becomes like an array
only right?
Then why do we need this?
So we need not search the whole
array.
There is a, you know, special
concept there, but so far is
insertion clear for all of you,
yeah.
SURENDRA is right.
Number of you know elements that
I can insert in a linear probing
is not greater than what most
north only right.
So we will now look at insertion
is clear now.
So now we will also look at this
disadvantage, right?
Let's again do this insertion
quickly.
So far, you know I had inserted
result 41 and then you know you
had this 44 who had collided
with five and he did a linear
probe and he went to six.
So far so good.
OK.
What was this 44th legitimate
position?
Yeah.
Where was the deserving to
fight?
Play.
Fine.
5.
But where did he now go?
He went to six.
By doing so, he has actually
taken the place of someone else
who will deserve the position of
six.
Do you agree now when this 32
comes, 32 has is deserved
position as six when he comes he
will collide with this guy,
right?
So this is what happened here,
right?
He collided here.
He collided here and he kept on
going and this 32 went and took
the position of eight.
What was the legitimate place
for this?
Eight who deserved that eighth
position?
This 73 but when 73 came someone
else is here.
So he again keeps probing and he
goes here.
So can I tell that these
collisions because of this
linear probing concept go and
occupy someone else's legitimate
position, causing again future
collisions?
Is that correct?
Yes, no, this 44 and this 32,
they are going and occupying
Yes, Sir.
someone else's and that guy
comes, he will also again call
it and he'll go and take someone
else's position.
So this chain will keep on
continuing and that is what is
this disadvantage which was
mentioned here?
Yeah, this is called as primary
clustering colliding items lump
together, causing future
collisions to cause a longer
sequence of probes during
insertion again and again they
will go take someone else's and
they will again cost future
collision and so on.
This will keep happening, right?
So this is called US primary
clustering.
This happens in linear probing.
Yeah, insertion all of you
clear.
If a list of the keys are given,
if the hash function and table
are given, will you be able to
do insertion?
This is the example, yeah.
This is more space efficient,
but this has this, you know
problem of you can only
accommodate a capital N you
cannot do more than that right?
So now we will go for the
search.
Yeah.
No.
Slowly we will go for the
search.
How do you search?
As usual, take the key, put it
in the hash function.
The hash function will give you
the hash value or the index.
Go to that cell.
Robe consecutive locations until
one of the following occurs.
What is it?
An item with the key case found,
then return key present.
An empty cell is found, then
return no such key.
N cells have been unsuccessfully
probed, then return.
No such key.
Is this clear?
All of you.
So there are three cases after
you find out your hash value,
you will go start looking from
that A of I position either
three things will happen.
Either that key will be found.
You have to probe again, right?
You will not just look for that
one cell alone.
You'll keep probing you later.
Find that key or if you find an
empty cell, you will tell that
no such key.
You will not go to the end of
the array, right?
So Ruby in an array you don't
know that you'll have to start
and go till the end.
But here if I find an empty cell
in between somewhere, I will
just stop my algorithm and I'll
say it is not there.
Yeah, but if the complete array
is full and there is no empty
cell, also there is no key also,
then you will again have that no
such key.
Let's take some examples.
It'll be even more clear.
Consider the following hash
table, the one that we just
created.
Hash function is given to us.
Search Oregon.
Find both are the same
operations.
Find 183157 so 3 examples have
been given.
Firstly, let do for 18.
How will you do that?
First you will put it for you
know your hash function.
You'll get 18 mod 13 as five.
Look at your file.
18 is equal to 18, so it is
success you have got it.
Yeah, there are some question
also while searching the
inherent hash key of a key with.
What is ANIKET?
Yeah.
What was that anyway?
We will cover this and then we
will go there anisha.
So 18 successful perfect 31.
31 Mod 13 is also five, so look
at your file.
Your 18 is not equal to 31, so
look at you.
Of 644 is not 3159 is not 3132,
is not 3122, is not 3131 is 31.
So you got it.
So at the 10th location you got
it as success and this is the
location where that item is.
What about 57?
Yeah.
What is 57 mod 13?
Real quick.
Play 5 again.
For you again.
No.
So you will start probing from
here, right?
So 57 is not 1844, not 57, and
you'll keep probing till here 73
is not 47.
You'll probe the next cell and
this is empty.
So now you will tell this is not
there.
You are real quick, SURBHI.
Yeah, there are three cases.
You will compute the hashed
value.
You will go to that cell.
You'll do consecutive probing
until one of this happens.
Either the key is found or it is
not found.
Meaning, when there is an empty
cell, right when there's an
empty cell, you will stop your
algorithm and say this is not
there.
That is where there is an
important difference between an
array and this right in an
array, you cannot do that.
You'll have to, you know, keep
searching.
But here, if there is an empty
cell, you will stop your
algorithm and say there is no
such key.
Yeah.
Otherwise, there can be a case
where all the N items itself are
filled, and even then we don't
have a key, so even there the
complexity is big of end due to
probing said yes, yeah.
So let's you know, check this.
I wanted to search for a team
again.
I applied the same hash
function.
I got the hash value S5.
I went to a of five.
I got the key so search is
successful.
I want to search for 3131 more
13 is again 5I go here it is not
31 so I keep probing.
I keep probing here and finally
I went to 31.
I got that so search is
successful.
Now I look for 5757 mod 13 is
also again 5, but 18 is not
equal to 57.
So look for a of six, then a of
seven.
So keep doing that.
You went till A of 11 which is
7373 is not equal to 57.
Then you hit an empty cell the
moment you see an empty cell,
you can confidently tell that 57
is not there.
Why can you confidently tell
this?
Because if 57 was there, it
would have collided and it would
have been somewhere here,
otherwise it would have collided
all these places.
It would have got inserted here.
Right, it cannot be the case
that this is empty and then this
has gone here.
Got it.
Anyways, getting this point.
Sort of.
Somebody has removed that key.
But but if if this complete
array is full in that case for
If you deleted the key.
57 it will search till till 4th
cell.
Correct.
Yeah, that goes through this.
The third you know, case if N
cells have been unsuccessfully
That's it.
proved.
Of course, complexity is again,
we go again, right?
Yeah, that's the thing.
Yeah.
At the end, all these cases are
big of north only.
Yeah, the whole of hashing
concept is big O of N in the
worst case.
Yeah.
But you believe you should not
have that?
Yeah, a little later, we will
look at that.
You will never allow a hash
table to be fully filled, so it
is very rare that you go into
the worst case.
What about key 25?
Yeah, you again just quickly try
that. Yeah.
What is 25 mod 13?
Yeah, real quick, yeah.
Well.
Yeah, 12.
You directly go to 1212 is
empty, so you declare that 25 is
not there, which is correct.
25 is not there in this hash
table right?
This this is the algorithm and
perfect.
So now let's take one of the you
know edge cases of this
algorithm, I want to delete
something.
Yeah, for delete again as usual.
I don't know if the key that you
will give me is there or not, so
I should first do a search if it
is there then I will delete it.
Consider the following hash
table and the hash function.
I've been given the same hash
table.
I've been told to delete 1818
mod 13 is 5, I go to five, I
find that 18 is present, so I'll
delete it and it became empty.
Now.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you deletion.
You first search for it and once
you search it, you will go ahead
and delete it.
You deleted it.
No, you will tell me.
What is I'm going to do a
search.
I'm going to do a search on 31.
What is 31 Watt?
133130 is fine, correct?
We go to five.
What did the search algorithm
say?
Whenever you find an empty cell,
what will happen?
Yeah, exactly.
That's what we're doing for a
week.
Yeah, we are searching for 31
now, 31 more, 13 is 5.
I go to this particular cell and
I see that this is empty.
So what did the search algorithm
say when a cell is empty?
Anyone.
Stop.
Stop there itself.
Yeah, they told to stop and he
told to stop and tell that that
Yeah.
algorithm is not there.
I mean that element is not
there, so I stop my search.
I tell that 31 is not there.
What is 31 there in this?
Yes, it is here.
Yes.
So there is some conflict here.
There is some problem happening.
If I delete something randomly
it would cause problems for the
items who had collided on that
cell.
Yeah, key not phone, but
actually keys.
There pretty one is here because
31 had collided with that 18 and
he kept on probing and he went
here.
So what do we do now?
Right.
So there are plenty of
solutions, but I want to just
give you the solution which is a
very old one, but a very
powerful one.
Yeah, just see what people have
proposed.
Yeah, cannot just delete the key
we want bring.
So might make it impossible to
retrieve any key K during whose
insertion we had probed this
slot and found it occupied,
right?
Similar to our example 18 was
there and because of that 18
this 31 got probed and he went
somewhere else.
Now if you delete this 18, then
later the search algorithm will
not work.
So use a special value available
when you delete a key from a
slot.
What are you doing?
You delete a value you choose.
Don't leave it empty, but put a
marker there, maybe a dollar,
maybe a person, some symbol.
Right.
You can also put it as available
now.
This available will be
interpreted in different ways by
different algorithms.
Search would treat available as
though the slot holds a key that
is not match the one being
searched for and it will
continue to probe.
There's actually.
Is there any element there?
Yeah, real quick, simple and
others.
Exactly.
This is a placeholder, right?
Yes.
Actually it is not there right?
I deleted it so there is no
element physically there, but I
put a marker there so when the
search algorithm comes, when it
sees something like that, it
will imagine that there is some
number here but that is not the
one that I'm looking for.
So it will continue to search,
whereas when a insert algorithm
comes, it knows available means
it is actually available.
So little inserted there, so
let's see the example again.
Same case I want to delete 18
but now after deleting 18 I'll
put it as a.
So now when a search algorithm
works great available, treat
this A as though the slot holds
a key that does not match the
one being searched for and
continue.
So I'll continue to probe.
44 is not 3149, is not 31, and
so on, and I will get this 31.
So I'm happy.
Whereas if I now want to again
insert an element, let's say I
want to insert 5757 is not there
in this list.
What is 57 mod 13 again 5?
So he will directly come and use
this slot, right?
All that this is actually
available, there is nothing
here.
So he will insert 57 here and he
will use that location.
Can't it be achieved after uh
place adjustment?
So that's the problem, right?
I need to do a lot of
adjustments.
I don't know how many of them
you know got probed or, you
know, collided because of this.
So it's a very simple way that
just put a search algorithm will
treat it as it is occupied, but
not the one I'm looking for.
So I will keep probing again and
insert will actually use that
and he will use it as though it
is an empty space.
How did you guys understand
this?
What we did, it's a very simple
solution.
Yeah, two algorithms will
interpret the same thing in
different fashions.
What does this concept in
computer science I mean?
Not exactly this, but you can
modify the interpretations or
you know operations, behaviors
and all that. Right.
OK, I don't want to deviate.
Then I will end up teaching
something else.
But yeah, this is all like, you
know, polymorphism and stuff,
right?
Yeah, very good.
Cool.
That being said, that is about,
you know, linear probing, right.
So now let's talk about load
factor.
Yeah, there are two more.
Yeah.
So as I told, there is something
called, as you know, quadratic
probing and double hashing.
But that is not there in your
syllabus for mid semester.
So I don't want to confuse you
by now itself covering all that
and we don't have a lot of time
also we just have another 20
minutes.
So we will pause it and we will
do that later to submit up
search and delete will not use
the space.
Uh insert will uh use the space?
Exactly correct, but search and
will delete will actually
interpret it as though there is
some key there, correct?
Otherwise, the search algorithm
would have failed, so it'll
assume there is some key here,
but not the one I'm looking for,
so it will go ahead and keep
search.
But so now let's discuss about
this very small concept called
loads.
Suppose that the bucket arrays
of capacity capital N and there
are yen entries in the hash
table.
So capital N is always capacity.
But a small N is the number of
entries in the hash table.
So load factor is defined as
Lambda which is given by small
north by capital right.
This load factor has to be kept
below a small constant,
preferably below one, and
usually it is .75 or 75%.
So in databases, have you done
something like this where if
your database is almost getting
full, you try to immediately,
you know, attach more storage
right database as a service
people have been doing all that
these days, right?
Yes. No.
Is it load balancing?
Yeah.
Something like that, right?
So when you feel that you are,
you know, almost hitting the
threshold, you add more
resources to it.
That's what we are telling here.
We are telling here that if a
hash table is completely filled,
there are two problems.
The first problem is you cannot
insert anymore if you are using
open addressing, right?
If you are either using your
linear probing, quadratic
probing, or your double hashing,
capital N is the threshold, you
cannot go beyond that separate
chaining you can, but here you
can't, but somehow you have to
insert more items than what you
do, right?
So there is a problem.
The second problem is the one
that's where we had brought in
where you told that if the coal
hash table is filled, then what
are the difference between a
normal array in this?
Because in both of them you are
ending up searching the whole
you know structure, right?
So what we want to do is we want
to always keep only 75% as
filled maximum.
So after every insert, after
every insert you will calculate
Lambda right after every insert.
This small end is increasing, so
this whole Lambda is also
increasing and you will check if
it is less than 75%.
It's less than 75% is OK.
Otherwise you will do something
called as rehashing whenever we
add elements.
It is important to keep the load
factor below a specified
constant, so increase the size
of the bucket array.
Basically, if it is going above
that constant then increase the
size of the bucket array, double
the size of the original array,
meaning immediately you'll
double it.
You will not increase it by one
or two and so on.
You will double it, but while
doubling it, that new number
might not be a prime number,
correct?
For example, if capital N is 13,
double that of 13 is 26, but 26
is not a prime number, so you
will choose the nearest prime
number next to prime number,
change the hash function to
match this new size.
Since this capital N has now
changed, the whole hash function
will now change then
reperforming the whole hashing
right, insert all the existing
hash table elements into this
new bucket array using the new
hash function.
Such a size increase and hash
table rebuild is called as
rehashing.
Yeah, we'll take an example.
So read this question properly.
What is the load factor of this
hash table?
Can you real quick tell me the
load factor of this?
Or I mean.
Yeah, Lambda is equal to what is
small in here 12345.
.7.
Sorry, I have.
By by 7.
Data .71.
My telephone.
That's it, right?
Elements of the hash table are
rehashed into another hash table
of size 17.
So what does the 17?
The 17 is the new hash value,
you know size or new capacity,
New capital N.
right?
Next next prime number.
Right, right.
So how did we get that?
So basically we took seven and
seven into two was 14 for us,
but 14 is not Prime, 15 is not
Prime, 16 is not Prime, 17 is
prime.
So we took that and now the new
hash function has become xmod
17.
So we have to rehash this whole
thing.
Technically, there's still some
.71 only right.
It is less than 75, but we have
been told to rehash so we are
going to do it.
How do we do that?
Very, very important.
A lot of students will recreate
this table with, say, 02, you
know, 16 or plays, as you know,
17.
But they will just copy the six
here.
They'll just copy this and so
on, which is completely wrong.
Yeah, you cannot copy it,
because now the whole hash
function has changed.
So you have to apply the new
hash function of again game mode
17, so 6 mod 17 the six only, so
that will go to the index 6 like
15 will go to 15.
Mod 17 is 15 only, so it'll go
to the 15th index and so on.
So now for this one.
What is Lambda?
Is this 6 by 17?
Is that right?
If I buy something, sorry.
Yeah.
By by 17.
So which is way less than your,
you know previous case who?
This is your rehashing.
So rehashing every time it
crosses threshold value,
wouldn't it be a performance
issue?
Yes, it'll be so that is why you
need to choose a very careful
yen value for your application.
If you're randomly choose some
prime number, it will be a
problem.
You need to be very careful on
what is my expected load and
what is it that I'm going to
store here and depending on that
you will choose your yen and
also when you are rehashing
immediately you are going to do
end size and if that is not a
prime you will go to the next
nearest prime cool.
It is very unlikely that
immediately this bigger size
will also get filled correct.
For example, here there's only
seven, but now this has become
17.
So the next time when I need
rehashing, what will be the next
size?
Yeah, 17 tools are and the
nearest prime and so on.
Right.
So this will, you know, go
bigger and bigger.
30.
So you are not doing every other
day, right?
Cool.
Yeah, go ahead.
You have some questions.
To this .7 this is .3 you have
reduced your Lambda value 2
lesser one usually N is not
known in advance for hash table
data structure.
Yes.
No, not known.
Meaning we have to determine
that right when you are going to
use it hash table for your own
use case, you'll have to 1st
talk to, you know, domain
experts on what is it that I'm
planning to store here and is it
like a streaming data that keeps
coming if it's a streaming data
then this is a bad data
structure, right?
Should not use hash table to do
all that right?
So it depends on what type of
data you are storing and what is
the probability N and domain
experts will tell you that N and
again as I told from then you
are going to 2 NA little greater
than two N based on prime, then
again 2 N from that and so on.
So you're not going to keep
doing it, so that's fine.
Yeah.
So like so for example.
So.
So in system design like uh,
based on the capacity, this can
be decided.
Correct.
But when it comes to like the
data structure like the data
types, basically that we have in
a programming language for
Uh-huh.
example, we have like hash table
or like dictionary right which
Correct.
are anyways using hashing.
So in those like data types we
we do not have the known
Correct.
capacity known in advance here.
A control over it, correct?
So that is because these
programming language hash table
implementations will
automatically take care of this.
You get it right?
Just like, uh, an analogy would
be your CPU usage.
When your CPU is almost hitting
90 threshold and so on, it will
automatically, you know, kill
certain processes and it will
bring the you know processor or
I mean CPU usage to around
6070%.
Again like that your inbuilt
things that Python offers or say
Java offers.
They already know that your hash
table is getting filled, so they
will be internally able to
rehash certain things.
Yeah.
So if you're directly using a
library, then you don't need any
of this.
Yeah, but this course is all
about what is the actual
fundamental principle of these
data structures, right?
If you directly use a hash set
or a hash table or a hash map,
then you need to just you know,
start using it.
You don't need to worry about
these intricacies of Lambda and
so on.
Yeah.
Uh said.
Uh, just one more thing.
Yeah.
So what is the significance of
converting the size from 7 to 17
like uh, even though our
requirement has been fulfilling
when we are taking it as seven.
So I mean.
No, it is not seven, right?
I mean it's slowly your
requirement is going down like
you are in the hazard of when
two more new items come here
then your whole hash table will
get filled, right?
So it's a very precautious
mether.
OK.
OK, cool.
So when it is 75% full, you want
to proactively increase the size
Cool.
Got it, Sir. Umm.
rather than waiting for this to
get filled.
And then you know, not having
space to insert anything in hash
OK.
table.
So you're proactively creating a
new table.
OK.
Uh, so, uh, just follow up
questions, Sir.
So uh is that any?
Uh, static value that it should
get changed with certain amount.
That amount is actually fixed or
like OK .75 rounds.
Yes.
Yeah, .75 right, 75%, yeah,
around 75%.
Fine, fine.
OK.
Thank you, Sir.
Thank you.
Got it.
Thank you, Sir.
All that being said, yeah.
So as we already saw, for all of
them, we go of N only right?
That is the complexity, but it
has its own advantages, right?
So you can do quickly searches
and you know things like that
and applications someone was
asking so DNS resolutions like
google.com is actually not
google.com, right?
It's actually an IP address, so
those could also be.
You know the address can serve
as the key and you know things
like that.
You can use password
verification using.
You know, hashing compilers also
use them internally.
Online spell checking tools,
right?
Any spell checker tools for a
correct spelling, you can, you
know, calculate the hash value
and keep it for anything which
is similar but wrong.
It's hashed value will be
different, right?
So it'll be able to give you
some red lines and so on.
And you know, it's way beyond
all this, but it uses somewhere,
you know, hashing.
So I've given it.
You can explore more about it,
pattern matching and plagiarism,
right?
So for example, if two people
have submitted an assignment and
their hashed values are exactly
the same, then what does it mean
then?
It means the key itself is the
same.
If the key itself is the same,
it means two people have exactly
submitted the same document,
correct?
Yes, no. Yeah.
Alright so.
So in some ways I mean I'm just
throwing some ideas to you, but
plagiarism check and all that is
way more than, you know, just a
hashing.
You will learn about these in
your upcoming courses in you
know your information retrieval
or NLP and all that, but you
could also use certain data
structures like these in them.
So I'm just, you know, throwing
those.
So the journey so far, what all
we have done right?
Senator, I have one question
that might be silly, but why we
So can someone, yeah.
cannot imply this hashing
technique in error also like 75%
then error will increase size of
error will increase.
Something like that.
Size of error.
Meaning, what do you mean by
that?
It it it it it it?
Sorry Eric, size of Arabic
countries.
Yeah, that is what we are doing,
right.
Yeah, that is what we are doing.
I mean when it hits 70%, we are
going to automatically change
yen to two NF.
2 N is not a prime.
The next nearest prime so
automatically this whole new
table will get created.
Rehashing will happen.
Who?
Why they are not studying in the
error data databases like sorry
data, data structure in error
data structures?
Why we are calling this is a
hashing in hashing.
No in ARAY.
Also, we are doing and that is
what is called your array list,
right?
So there is a concept called
array list in your programming
languages, right?
They call that an array.
List can grow or expand in array
list there is no problem of
Oops.
capital N right?
It can keep growing, so that is
what they do in an array list.
Array also can grow.
OK, together think of.
So in your amortized analysis
class in webinar, this was
covered right.
If you hit a threshold in an
array also you can extend it.
You can double the size and then
we spoke about amortization.
Yeah, this someone remember that
I did not take the class.
Yes.
It was in the webinar.
Yeah, in area also you can do
that.
You can actually double the size
and keep doing that, but in
array for search there is no
benefit.
You'll have to still search all
the elements, but here if I want
to search for a key six, I'm not
going to start from the
beginning.
I'm going to directly do 6 mod
17 and 6.
Mod 17 is 6 only directly come
here and check if that is the
answer or not.
I mean the element that I'm
looking or not, right?
So it is helping us in the
search part, yeah.
Yes, Sir.
What did you think?
You.
Yes, yes.
For real quick will tell me what
all we have done so far.
Yeah, maybe one person.
One class?
Yeah.
First class, what did we do?
OK, let me really quickly you
know, tell you so first class we
Order of growth.
didn't do array and so on.
Yeah, we actually, yeah.
I go, I'll go ahead.
Teams you don't quote.
Right.
So firstly we got a motivation
towards why is data structures
Uh.
and algorithms important, and we
you know to get from there.
We told if one person is solving
a problem and another is not,
then there is a clear winner.
But if multiple people are
solving the same problem, then
there is a problem of which is
better.
Better meaning based on time and
space.
So we told time complexity,
space complexity, order of
growth, pseudo code and how do
you, you know, derive the
complexity using pseudo code,
right?
There is something called
accounting primitives.
You will count the primitives.
You will simplify it.
You will ignore the lower order
term.
You will cancel the constant and
what you get.
You will put it in your
asymptotic notation.
We go.
Yeah, this was all the first
class and then we went to the
second class.
We started learning about some
small tricks and myths and about
if there is one loop, it is yen.
If it is 2 loops, it is North
Square.
If it is 3 loops, it's N cube.
All that is wrong.
It all depends on the body of
the loop.
What if I have a break?
What if I have a continue right?
Things like that.
So we told don't go by just
crude logic algorithm analysis
is a very systematic step by
step process.
If a code is given, you'll have
to analyze it line by line and
then try to derive it.
And we also told if there is,
you know there is a type of
algorithm called recursion where
you call itself again and again.
There's a base case and all
that, so if it is a normal
iterative algorithm, you could
just write the pseudocode, count
the primitives, see how many
times it executes, summarize it,
simplify it.
Get that, Sir.
But if it is a recursive
algorithm, you might have to
create something called as a
recurrence relation and that
recurrence relation has to be
solved, right?
You can either use your
substitution method or you can
use the ADOC tree method or you
can use the masters theorem.
Masters Theorem had a lot of sub
cases and all those things
right?
This is all we had learned.
And then in the third class, we
got started with linear data
structures.
We told what is an array, what
is the stack?
What is a queue?
Whether what principle does
stack follow?
Yeah, stack last in, first out,
right leaf and Q follows first
in first out.
Boston.
So for all of them, we learned
operations.
What is tall?
You know top what is, you know,
NQ, what is dequeue, what is
pushing, what is popping, how
can you implement a stack or a
queue.
You can either use array or you
can use a linked list.
Then we learned linked list,
doubly linked list all those
properties and we closed that
day and then in the fourth
session we told not about
nonlinear data structures.
If you want to represent the org
structure, not all of them are
linear, there is a relationship
between the you know parent and
child, so that was about trees
and about a lot of different
types of trees, right?
Binary tree proper binary tree.
Perfect binary tree complete
binary tree.
A lot of properties around them
about inorder traversal,
preorder traversal, postorder
traversal, all that we looked at
and then we put a constraint on
the traversals or I mean the
tree itself and told that if the
parent nodes are greater than
the children, it is a Max sleep.
If the parent nodes are smaller
than the children, it is min
heap, right?
We learned about they property
is, you know, shape property.
He property.
What is heaps?
How to do insertion?
What does he P fication EP
fication is just the umbrella
name, right?
All that you are doing this.
It's a process for converting a
non heap into a heap.
Either you can use Max Heapify
or min epiphany and then we also
learned about some applications
of heaps before that we inserted
things into heap and we learned
principles like you know down
heap bubbling up, heap bubbling
and about you know applications
of heap which is heap sort
whatever numbers are given
create a heap then delete
everything as a result what you
get is a sorted order.
Then we learned priority queues,
which is also at another
application of heap and then we
stopped about keeps and we got
into graphs for a network type
of a data structure where there
is no actual routed you know
three where there can be any
number of routes or there is no
connection.
Is that?
As you know parent child where
it is more like a network
Of them.
structure.
Enough have you with me now.
Yeah.
And he was late.
Interview.
Yeah.
Who's that?
Who's unmuted?
Yeah, huh.
How can you please mute?
Yeah.
Cool.
Uh, so then we got started with,
you know, graphs like where it's
a network type of data
structure.
And we saw both a lot of
terminologies.
Again, like you know what is
adjacent edge?
What is, you know, a subgraph?
What is degree?
What is, you know, all those
things.
And we also learned about the
types of graph traversal right?
You can do it using BFS.
You can do it using DFS or you
know, although there are also
directed undirected edges and so
one.
But we have also not done a lot
of things about directed graphs.
Directed graphs are always
interesting, right?
So there's a possibility that I
can go to a place, but I cannot
go to some other places, right?
More like a one way, two way and
so on.
So we will explore more about
graphs in the later part of the
course.
We will learn algorithms like
you know, shortest path like
minimum spanning tree, a lot
more things right?
We will learn that later, but
for now we just spoke.
What is a graph as a data
structure?
And then we learned about BST
which is putting some clauses
believing it will help us.
All smaller values go to left,
all greater values go to right
that follows in every level,
every node and you know we
learned about insertions,
deletions today and all that.
But that's skewed.
Ness was a problem.
He could still not help us.
Complexity became big of yeah.
Yeah.
Maybe then finally completed BSD
and learned about what is
hashing?
What is collision?
How do you resolve collision?
What is separate chaining?
What is linear probing, so
quadratic probing and double
hashing is also like linear
probing only.
It follows the same principles,
but it's a very small concept.
We will take it up after the mid
semester exam.
Apart from this you had UH-2
webinars in the first webinar we
spoke about, you know
applications of stacks and also
about you know, how do you
convert expressions or evaluate
expressions and what is
amortized analysis and you know
in the second one we also, you
know learned more about trees
and about you know also
selection sort.
I believe how did you learn
about selection sort in the
second webinar?
He is so.
Yeah.
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Uh.
Perfect.
Yeah.
So I wish I had taken that.
The Sudoku was given.
OK.
OK, perfect.
And then yeah, that's where we
are.
So we are now going to take a
break for our uh mid semester
exam and all the rest.
So the mid semester exam, so the
portions for mid semester exam
will be till what we covered
today including the webinars and
but I will put a very clear
announcement.
Yeah, I'll also check with
Professor again and I'll put an
announcement maybe by tomorrow
on what exactly is the portion,
but it'll be till what we have
covered today.
Do you have an eye on it?
And a sample paper or a past
paper.
Uh, and so on will be uploaded.
Uh, tomorrow again, with the
same announcement.
I'll also be posting some
papers, but a word of caution.
Uh.
For a lot of past few years.
Uh, the exam has been online
mode.
Yeah.
So the mid semester exam EC2
right?
That was also open book for the
last few semesters, so I'll be
uploading some past papers, but
don't get confused with that
because now it is different.
Right now it is going to be a
closed book exam, right?
Traditionally, it was closed
book.
I mean always bits Pilani
follows mid semester is closed
book final exam is open book.
That is the way it has been
always working, but during the
COVID when it all became online
and things like that, how could
you ensure closed book, right.
So that is why mid semester also
became open book.
But now we are back to our
traditional technique, right?
So it will be a closed book
exam.
It will be online, but at the
Institute as end, but again for
those folks who are not in India
and so on, there is you know you
will get separate communication.
Don't worry about that.
You will get things from them.
Yeah, it will be a subjective
exam, meaning it is not MCQ.
It will be a written exam where
you either type it in the tool
or you write it in a four sheets
and take a photograph and
weightage will be 30%.
At least in our course will not
confuse.
Will not go with percentage and
all that.
The example we were 30 marks
there will not be any options in
the exam.
It'll be attend.
All right, it will be exactly
summing it for 30 marks, the
duration will be 2 hours and you
might get a few more minutes for
upload, right?
So two hour, 10 minutes or so.
I'm not very sure about that,
but the paper will be designed
keeping in mind 2 hours, right?
So if there is any question,
should we put in a discussion
forum or email to Duchess?
Yeah.
So while preparing inside our
section again this is a lot of
confusion with your batch.
I have not faced this for a long
time, but certainly again this
has cropped up.
So again repeat.
So just let me know once you're
able to see this browser real
quick.
Once you are able to go to our
course, there will be a
Yes.
discussion forum here.
Don't use this.
Yeah, so this discussion forum
is for assignments or for any
emergency stuff like, you know,
you don't get the sample paper
and you know some generic topic
which is helpful for the whole
batch only then you have to use
this discussion.
Otherwise, go into our section,
go into Section 1, which is our
section.
Once you're going to discussion,
there will be another discussion
inside that which is only for
our section, right?
So use these to ask your
questions and I'll be answering.
And if at all there is
something, just feel free to
directly, you know, write to me
as well.
Yeah, I'll also be available.
So you can put that, but during
the exam during the exam in the
paper, if you have any questions
and so on, you cannot
communicate.
Yeah, you will not be able to
use discussion or write to, you
know, email and any of that.
You will assume something and
you will write the assumption in
the answer sheet that this is
what I'm assuming and this is
what I'm solving, but 99% you
will not not have any need for
assumptions 1.
The question will be very clear
and it'll hopefully not have any
mistakes also, but if at all
there is something, assume that
this is what is given in the
question and go ahead and solve
it in that way.
Cool.
So that's pretty much I had.
So there are some exercises as
usual.
So in these exercises there are
something related to this
quadratic probing or other
things.
So you can leave those for the
time being.
Like these options are not yet
covered in the class, you can
just focus on linear probing and
separate chaining for now.
Right.
So that being said, so all the
very best. Yeah.
So it's your first maybe exam
with bits WILP, so it'll be
interesting, so prepare well and
give your best shot.
And yeah, so do we have an
option for questions?
No, no alternate questions.
Yeah, you'll have exactly the
person paper summing up.
For 30 marks, you'll have to
attend all.
Yeah.
And the questions will be for a
different marks.
They'll all not be for the same
marks.
It can be like, you know, 31
Mark questions.
It can be 15-2 more questions or
it can be 2 marks, 3 marks, 5
marks.
It can be one single question or
any combination.
You will have to attend all
questions and that will sum to
30 marks, right?
So that being said, so go ahead.
Sir, do we need to?
So do we need to carry mobile
for scanning the paper which we
are writing and upload it?
Uh, I'm not really sure about
these operations because now I
heard that, you know, there is a
new vendor for the example
portal.
There is physical exams where
you go to center and so on.
I would suggest carry your
mobile phone and take the best
call during the exam like there
will be individual letters and
they will assist you on you know
how to go about it and you know
OK so.
if mobiles are allowed and so
on.
But go prepared with all your
resources and if I were you, I
will take like 5000 a four
sheets.
I will maybe write my name or
print my name roll number like
you have two exams per day,
right?
So you will at least need say
3044 sheets.
So all that is a one minute is
still a saving right?
You may not keep writing your
name and rule number in every
sheet, so try to do all these
things like a pre work and.
Go enjoy writing the exam.
Yeah, I would only suggest that,
yeah, don't.
You know, take it as a you can
take.
Don't take it very personally
that you know I mean exam and so
on.
Sheets will not be provided.
I'm not really sure.
Be prepared again.
The same thing like this is not
happening on campus, so just
carry your own sheets, carry
mobile phone, laptop, all that.
And if at all there is something
you can, you know, use that.
So do that part and we will not
be having any classes till your
exams complete.
So we will again be meeting
somewhere in mid February only,
right?
We have the next week as two
subjects.
The week after that is again 2
subjects and the week after that
will be makeup.
Exams.
So we will meet only after three
more weeks, which is like more
than you know exactly after one
month is what the 4th week from
now is when we will be meeting,
right?
Yeah, Feb 10.
Perfect, right.
So that's, uh, pretty much that
I had.
So all the best and you know,
I'll just stop the recording.
Excuse.
I'll still be there for some
time.
Excuse me, Sir.
Yes, Sir.